sand rocks and vast emptiness the
Chihuahuan Desert in the US state of New
Mexico stretches hundreds of kilometers
this is where groups of hundreds of
migrants mostly families from Central
America have chosen to surrender
themselves to the u.s. Border Patrol the
question is why is a growing number of
people choosing to cross in this hot and
barren place last December a seven year
old girl died after journeying here more
than three thousand kilometers with her
father from Guatemala she was in u.s.
Border Patrol custody her body
temperature was more than 41 degrees it
was a horrible thing that never should
have happened
if the people hadn't been forced into
the desert it wouldn't have happened
Michael Sims works at the general store
in the nearby town of hijita he says the
US border wall that guards urban areas
and the greater number of border agents
their lead migrants to cross in more
remote places even so he says the
migrants caused no trouble here he says
Trump calling this an invasion is wrong
there was no invasion of people a lot of
people came they came quietly they came
honestly as honestly as they could a few
blocks away boniva and Bob denzler say
they are worried about the number of
people crossing so close to their home
in those large groups you don't know how
many of them are criminals are part of
the cartel coming through and trying to
be part of that group to get into the
country the married couple says like
most Americans who live in this
politically conservative town they
support Trump's border policies I feel
he's he's doing the best job he can do
with what he's had to work with this is
an ongoing problem that's been here for
three years as the desert heat soars the
number of migrants crossing the u.s.
southern border has dropped to 72,000 in
July that's still much higher than
previous years and the fear is more
people will die in the attempt Heidi Joe
Castro al Jazeera
antelope Wells New Mexico